[Music]
on this monday night an indigenous
family's
anger and anguish colton bouchie's
mother
vindicated after being vilified by the
rcmp
i did not deserve to be treated the way
i was treated
the next chapter for the two michaels
our focus must remain
on finding a way to bring them home as
another secret trial in china
ends without a verdict fire and floods
the spew of lava
800 years in the making and a disaster
of the century
down under plus astronomical achievement
this was my dream the helicopter making
history in space
and the canadian who broke barriers to
help make it happen
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
the grieving mother of a young
indigenous man killed nearly
five years ago had her heartbreak
compounded by the way she was treated
following colton bushi's death a
civilian watchdog found rcmp
officers behaved in a discriminatory
manner the night they came to deliver
the news
debbie baptiste says she's fighting to
spare other indigenous families the
injustice
she had to suffer it was pure torture
felt like we were swept under the carpet
we were never going to get
justice when we when were we going to be
heard
that's how it felt felt like i was
forever
fighting a battle that could never be
won
it was a case that sparked outrage
across the country global's ryan kessler
joins us from saskatoon with more on the
reaction to the review
ryan robin colton bushey's mother says
her family was not going to stop
fighting for justice and according to
the civilian review and complaints
commission
she deserved better treatment than what
she received from police
the rcmp watchdog's findings represent
long-awaited acknowledgment of what
debbie baptiste endured hours
after her son's death if colton
could hear me now
he'd be proud that we continued fighting
and we never gave up
the civilian review and complaints
commission for the rcmp determined
baptist was discriminated against
when officers told her about bushy's
death the report determined police told
her to get it together
and smelled her breath you swarm her
house
you search your house you call her a
drunk
and you call her a liar baptiste lawyers
say police showed the family of the
accused more compassion
than the victim's family there's a big
difference
and that that is systemic racism
the commission highlighted investigative
shortcomings like an suv
being exposed to significant rainfall
washing away bushy's blood
an rcmp news release disproportionately
focused on a theft investigation
connected to bushy's friends
despite no evidence of bushy attempting
to steal anything
this case is not unique
to indigenous people to indigenous
families
indigenous people are treated like this
all the time by the current
justice system by the rcmp in a
statement saskatchewan rcmp
said the force is committed to
implementing all recommendations
and this report addresses many
unanswered questions about officer
conduct
saying it is our hope that the report
and the steps we have taken to implement
the recommendations
reinforces our commitment to
transparency and accountability
to the people we serve lawyers for
bushy's mother are now calling on
saskatchewan justice officials to
investigate
hateful racist remarks made on social
media
the lawyer saying that a public shaming
is not adequate punishment
robin ryan kessler in saskatoon thanks
brian
reynovac prime minister stephen harper's
former chief of staff
is suggesting that canada's former
defense chief general jonathan vance
was not truthful when asked about
allegations of sexual misconduct
prior to his appointment novak told the
house of commons defense committee today
that harper met with vance in march
2015 to ask about vance's alleged
inappropriate relationship
with a subordinate while serving in
italy novak says vance told harper he
was relieved the matter had been
reviewed and was behind him
and that harper also asked vance if
there was anything else he should know
about
novak also referenced global news's
exclusive interview with major kelly
brennan
who alleges she was involved in a
long-standing inappropriate relationship
with vance
i think it's clear that she made
extremely serious allegations
and if they are true and i have no
reason to doubt her
that means the general was not truthful
with the prime minister
in their meeting novak says the
conservative government was made aware
in july 2015
of a rumor that vance had an
inappropriate relationship with a
subordinate
while at cfb gagetown novak says an
investigation did not find any further
information that
warranted canceling vance's appointment
vance denies the allegations
another senior canadian forces member
has resigned from the military
lieutenant general christopher coats
admitted to having an affair
with a civilian while he served as the
deputy commander of norad
at its headquarters in colorado coates
returned to canada last year to become
the commander of the canadian joint
operations command
he says the decision to step aside is
his
in a message obtained by the canadian
press coats said after much reflection i
made this decision for my own personal
reasons
including what i believe would be in the
best interests of the canadian armed
forces
the department of national defense says
coates wasn't in violation of any rules
because the civilian was not under his
command
the much anticipated trial of michael
coverage in beijing has ended with no
verdict
chinese officials say that will come at
a later date
it's the same outcome we saw with
michael spavor last week
both canadians have been detained in
china for more than two years on spying
charges
canadian diplomats were refused entry to
both hearings
despite repeated calls for transparency
and as abigail beeman reports
the federal government says it is deeply
troubled by the situation
netherlands united kingdom
about two dozen countries stood outside
a beijing courthouse supporting
michael calvrig and canada the united
states is
deeply alarmed that chinese authorities
are now commencing a trial hopefully
we'll be able to
see him this morning get access to the
court that didn't happen
just like at michael spavor's trial
china blocked access over so-called
state secrets
and a foreign ministry spokesperson
blasted canada and all the allies for
showing up
claiming interference with china's
judicial sovereignty
we will continue to work closely with
our international partners
to pursue accountability and
transparency i have no words to explain
how
remarkable he has been how calm he has
been how
stable and focused he has been michael
kovrig's wife didn't sleep last night
or much the past few days china's
conviction rate tops 99 percent
and it's hard to try and prepare for a
guilty verdict
our focus must remain on finding a
solution
on finding a way to bring them home and
i think that solution all along has been
a diplomatic one and
now more than ever we simply need to get
on with it it has been
way too long this case is not the case
of the two michaels
this case is the three m's and until
a solution to the mung won joe
uh detention is also part of a
package where we're going to be having
more and continued painful moments like
this
in beijing a long day turned to night
canada's representative was still
outside the courthouse
with no new information from the other
side of the wall
we'll be following up with them to
register our protest of not having
had access to the trial and we'll be
demanding to see
michael kroveg very soon as two families
along with the world await two verdicts
abigail beeman global news ottawa
canada is imposing sanctions on four
chinese officials over horrific
human rights violations against minority
muslims in that country
the sanctions involve freezing assets
and a travel ban
the move is a coordinated effort with
the u.s britain and the european union
the countries are taking a stand over
mounting evidence of mistreatment and
abuse
of china's weaker population our chief
political correspondent david aiken
joins us now david what is the
significance of these sanctions
and where do they fit in the big picture
of canada-china relations
well this is just the sort of thing
robin that canada has actually been
advocating
broad coordinated international action
to address china's bad behavior in this
case as you mentioned the genocide that
china is committing against millions of
muslim uyghurs
in northwest china i'm told these
sanctions have been in the works for
some time
and are not a response to the trials of
the two michaels or really anything else
that happened in the last week but
what has made this coordinated action
possible
is the new approach from the biden
administration
having the united states aligned
diplomatically with canada
the eu and australia is very powerful uh
diplomatic sources are telling me
these sanctions have already provoked an
angry denunciation
by china and china has retaliated with
its own sanctions
against several europeans i'm told there
may be some sanctions against some
canadians
robin but david given all that's
happened in the last week on the two
michaels file their trials the u.s china
meetings in alaska
is canada any closer to getting them
home diplomatic sources again tell me
they believe that if anything
the outlook for the two michaels today
is likely
darker than it was this time last week
one thing the chinese feel the americans
insulted them
in alaska and if the americans now say
they want the two michaels to be treated
as if they were american citizens fine
the chinese say they'll keep them in
jail a little longer and
while the canadian side believes it is a
definite plus to have the u.s
weighing in on behalf of the two
michaels it also means the two michaels
are now players or chips in an ever
widening geopolitical contest
between the u.s and china and that could
complicate canadian efforts
to see the two michaels freed robin
david aiken in ottawa thanks so much for
your insight
there are more vaccines coming it's the
biggest week yet for shipments
more than two million vaccine doses are
set to arrive from pfizer biontec and
moderna
plus 1.5 million doses of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine are expected from
the u.s by the end of the month
vaccination programs across the country
are expanding
ontario residents 75 and older can now
book an appointment
in montreal people 60 and over are now
eligible
and montrealers can now receive their
vaccines at a pharmacy
eventually 1500 locations across quebec
will take part as supply ramps up about
125
000 shops will be administered in
pharmacies each week
alberta will delay its reopening plans
as cases of kova 19 rise
the province is seeing exponential
growth with the b-117 variant first
discovered in the uk
as heather urex west explains despite
facing pressure to ease restrictions
jason kennedy's government says it's too
risky right now
every student at this calgary high
school is now once again
back to learning from home after an
outbreak of covet 19 prompted officials
to shut the school
down i think right now the numbers are
making it very
clear that the virus is growing in the
community
the variants in particular are growing
at an extremely rapid rate
province wide the number of active cases
has jumped by 40 percent in the last
month with the bulk of those new
infections coming in the last seven
days the growth being fueled by the b117
variant
the seven day average number of new
infections is now doubling by the week
we're very concerned about what's
happening we've been saying for a while
that with the new variant increasing
throughout alberta that there was a
very good possibility of the third wave
and it looks like
that's what we're seeing alberta's
government has been facing tremendous
pressure to ease restrictions
at least two united conservative caucus
members took to social media monday
urging the province to proceed to step
three of reopening
but alberta's health minister says
making that move comes with too
much risk alberta now sits at 280
covet hospitalizations which is a rise
of 16
from a week ago and this is a problem
and a warning sign that we must take
seriously more than 80 percent of
alberta covet patients in icu
right now are under 65 years old under
the province's reopening framework the
next step would include easing
restrictions on things like indoor
gatherings
bingo halls and adult team sports but
tyler chandra says
for now those measures will have to wait
there will be no easing of any
restrictions at this time
this is the safe move it's the smart
move to
make for our province right now and it's
absolutely necessary
to help us avoid a third wave that would
take more lives
and once again put more pressure on the
hospital system
it's disappointing news for businesses
hoping to reopen again
but with covet cases surging dr james
talbot agrees it's the
right move to make our fear which is
based in reality is that we're going to
see
the second wave on steroids heather urex
west global news calgary
tonight's nhl game between the edmonton
oilers and the montreal canadiens has
been postponed because of covet fears
two montreal players are now on the
league's covet protocol list
they may not have the virus but may have
come in contact with someone who does
it's the first time a match-up in the
league's north division has been called
off because of covet the spring break
hangover in miami beach
coming up the curfew to control the
crowds
confidence in the astrazeneca vaccine
may be restored with new trial data out
of the u.s
showing it is safe and effective a study
completed by astrazeneca shows the
two-shot vaccine developed by oxford
university
is 79 effective against covet 19.
it also offered strong protection for
older people
who weren't well represented in earlier
studies
this study involved more than 30 000
participants
and scientists found there was no
increased risk of clots
that was a concern for several european
countries which temporarily suspended
the use of the vaccine the u.s is
bracing for what could be a fourth wave
of covid19 infections
case numbers are climbing and there are
fears more contagious variants will
spread rapidly
as millions of spring break travelers
head home from hot spots
like florida jackson proskow reports
the party is over in miami beach
where the mayor declared a state of
emergency after large
maskless groups swarmed city streets
at one point a police swat team tried to
break up the crowds
a nightly 8pm curfew is now in effect
until the end of spring break
it's a little ridiculous considering
that you know we are paying to stay on
the hotels on the strip and we can't
even have dinner
many came here looking for a vacation
from the virus
drawn in by florida's lacks restrictions
governor ron desantis is making the free
state
nomads we can come and have some good
but kovid hasn't taken
time off florida is the u.s hot spot for
cases of the more contagious variant
first detected in the uk the young
people out partying
are less likely to have been vaccinated
the likelihood of these individuals
contracting
and spreading the virus amongst
themselves is relatively high
when they then go back to their home
states they are
introducing the virus in cases are
already on the rise in at least 21
states including michigan
which is reporting more than a 50
percent increase in cases in just the
last week
we are a critical point in this pandemic
a fork in the road
it's not just virus variants from afar
similar home-grown mutations have sprung
up in california and new york and are
gaining steam
we must act now and i am worried that if
we don't take the right actions now
we will have another avoidable surge and
so the race is on to vaccinate
one in four americans has now received
at least their first dose
two months from now there will be enough
available for everyone in the country
until then the virus will continue to
pose a risk
even to those who ignore it jackson
prosco global news
washington still ahead feel the fire in
iceland
the eruption centuries in the making
the worst flooding in 60 years has
sparked a natural disaster in australia
about four months of rain have fallen in
a matter of days
at least 18 000 people have been forced
to flee
from the air new south wales looks like
the ocean swallowed it up
there's water as far as the eye can see
the situation is staggering
stretching from sydney to brisbane towns
and suburbs are already completely cut
off
and more rain is in the forecast a huge
fire has ripped through a rohingya
refugee camp in bangladesh killing at
least three people but it's feared
more could be dead
the flames erupted in the early morning
and took more than four hours to bring
under control
the cause is under investigation this
area of bangladesh grew into the world's
largest refugee camp in 2017
after more than 700 000 rohingya muslims
escaped a violent crackdown in
neighboring myanmar
up next meet the canadian woman hoping
to make aviation history
on the red planet
take a look at this spectacular view of
an erupting volcano in iceland the
dramatic drone footage shows lava
spewing and flowing
into rivers experts estimate about 300
000 cubic meters of lava have poured out
so far
thousands of people are flocking to the
site for a rare up-close look
no volcanic ash has been detected but
there are high levels of volcanic gases
the eruption which began friday is the
first in the area
in more than 800 years nasa's
perseverance rover is preparing to show
off
more of its moves on mars within the
rover's belly is the ingenuity
helicopter which nasa considers a
high-risk high-reward technology
it will become the first man-made device
to fly on another planet
during its maiden flight next month
tonight mike delay speaks to the
canadian engineer turned
rocket star playing a crucial role in
the mission
history is filled with the impossible in
1903 the wright brothers
changed the world and in a few weeks
nasa will try and change space
exploration
with its own moment of flight on mars
246 million kilometers from kitty hawk
north carolina i think so i mean we're
flying on another planet come on
like you know it's kind of it's kind of
crazy because
you know we we've only been flying on
earth for
for about a you know 100 years and now
we're saying we're going to go to
another planet where gravity is
different
ingenuity is its name and it's apropos
nasa had to design a helicopter that
could fly an atmosphere 99
thinner than on earth and survive minus
90 degrees celsius temperatures at night
after years of testing all that's left
is to prove it can fly on the red planet
what a journey to get to this point for
ingenuity and
systems engineer farah alibay i think
the best description is meandering for
my path and eventually i made it and i
made it where i wanted to be
mostly because this was my dream and now
the montreal-born
cambridge educated granddaughter of
immigrants who fled civil war in
madagascar
has become one of the new faces of nasa
but i think what we forget to talk about
is is all the failures along the way all
the sacrifices that had to happen
all of the wrong turns or the detours
that were taken
life certainly wasn't easy for alabama
growing up as a minority in quebec as a
francophone in england and overcoming
nasa's lack of diversity
she applied to the agency over 50 times
eventually getting noticed by the right
people
hi sophie it's why she relishes the
opportunity to speak with young girls
how long does the helicopter
fly so for our first flight we're not
gonna go very far we're actually just
hopping up and down
and so we're gonna fly about 40 seconds
to one minute right so the same way as
like
you don't learn to run first you walk
first so crawl that's what we're doing
alabay is a genius at this stuff but
it's the way she speaks to an
eight-year-old
that makes her a rocket star mike carley
global news toronto
that's a great story and that is global
national for this monday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
pishu falls manitoba
please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Applause]
[Music]
you